[Music]
one of the legacy of dr. Martin Luther
King jr. on this holiday we are taking a
close look at his inspiring words the
Civil Rights icon delivered the American
Dream Serban at Ebenezer Baptist Church
in Atlanta in 1965 we asked his children
Bernice and Martin Luther King the third
and his granddaughter Yolanda to read
part of it they say his words are just
as relevant today today some of the
problems that we confront in our own
nation by using as a subject the
American dream I chose this subject
because America is essentially a dream
it is a dream of a land where men of all
races of all nationalities and of all
Crees can live together as brothers the
substance of the dream is expressed in
these sublime words we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator with certain inalienable
rights among these are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
now we notice in the very beginning that
at the center of this dream is an
amazing universalism
it does not say some men but it says all
men
it does not say alright Nair but it says
all men which includes black men it does
not say all Gentiles but it says all men
which includes Jews
it does not say all Protestants but it
says all men which includes Catholics
that is something else that we notice in
this American dream which is one of the
things that distinguishes our form of
government was some of the other
totalitarian systems individual have
certain inherent rights that are neither
derived from or conferred by the state
there are gifts from the hands of the
Almighty God
for the American Dream reminds us that
every man is the heir of a legacy of
worse fulness but ever since the
founding fathers of our nation dream
this dream America has been something of
a schizophrenic personality on the one
hand we have proudly professed the noble
principles of democracy on the other
hand we have sadly practiced the very
antithesis of those principle
indeed slavery and segregation have been
strange paradoxes in a nation founded on
the principle that all men are created
equal but now more than ever before
America is challenged to realize its
noble dream for the shape of the world
today does not permit us the luxury of
an anemic democracy and the price the
price that the United States must pay
for the continued exploitation and
oppression of the Negro and other
minority groups is the price of its own
destruction the clock of Destiny is
ticking on it we must act now before it
is too late
it is trite but urgently true that if
America is to remain a first-class
nation
citizen all those years later the word
still holds up gives you goosebumps
Yolanda's 10 she's M okay the Third's
daughter named after his late sister
Yolanda she's something else too she's
got a great smile very nicely done
Eliana meant as our sister did that hard
to do that with no track